[Musique]
mais la vie si tout comme caen est
astucieux mais
elle est la jolie le plus est
à jouer et à gagner
[Musique]
du coup je prépare un potage bah oui là
je fais un nom papotage mais je suis en
train d'égaliser l'établi tu vois pas ce
qu'il y avait des bosses je suis en
train de faire et bien et puis faudrait
ciré abandon pour le ciré bah il
manquerait plus que ça va être juste un
an à toi j'aime bien l'odeur de la cie
ça sent le miel à c'est exact uem le
miel toi j'aime beaucoup me yet une
bonne 7e réseau je le chante comme il ya
oui oui pas aujourd'hui à pau pas mal
oui aujourd'hui je vais t'emmener encore
en voyage géographie toujours géographie
bon vous savez comment ça se passe
derrière cette fleur c'est quoi
aujourd'hui
1 c'est quoi la fleur chez dupuis sosie
assez du pissenlit oui tiens donc nous
allons découvrir la carte géographique
du pays en question
le drapeau et bonjour dans la langue du
pays et vous cherchez comme moi quelle
peut bien être ce pays tu veux que je
reste là où tu veux que j'aille me
cacher pendant que tu montes le pays
ben pourquoi tu peux pas rester là si je
veux bien au ballon
qu'est ce qui va sortir de là c'est tout
simplement la carte géographique du pays
tient décrit le moins bon c'est un un
pays qui composaient d'une d'une
presqu'île
oui et puis de différentes ils ont admis
sous les îles principales simplement et
comme dans le finistère bah si tu veux
qu'il faille avons pas le finistère a
non pas du tout d'ailleurs tu vois que
la capitale de ce pays se trouve dans
une île et non pas dans la partie qui
est la partie continentale du pays c'est
dans une île que ce que cette règle
c'est tout à fait exprès et alors le
drap alors le drapeau du pays
voilà bon c'est un drapeau qui est rouge
avec une croix blanche
le drapeau est rouge avec trois blancs
ou alors la croix et blanche avec son
rouge
c'est une ravissante une remarque
judicieuse et on dit bonjour dans la
langue du pays de la façon suivante la
prononciation n'est pas toujours garanti
ainsi nommé la laisse là prenez moi je
vous dirais que god d'agde méchant tacle
c'est vraiment ça ça ressemble un petit
peu au norvégien
oui oh bah écoute là tu nous a déjà aidé
tout ça c'est tout de même de la même
famille puisqu'il s'agit je pense que
vous savez maintenant d'un pays
scandinaves
en effet ce pays et le danemark
voilà c'est le danemark et la capitale
du danemark qui se trouvent ici c'est
copenhague copenhague copenhague comme
ils disent sur la chouette quand on dit
je suis désolé mais quand on dit god
d'agde on dit kopenhagen non parce que
les danois ne disent pas copenhagen
disent quelque chose comme shopping
quelque chose quand j'en ai entendu mais
c'est difficile à prendre mais ces
machines est assez je vais voir ce mot
si je vais dans le genre bah c'est tous
n'ont pas commencé à pleurer non alors
oui bon on va la voir sur le point
commun alors dans ces conditions vous
allez voir non messieurs pavillon prouve
tout quand tu as l'air complètement
désespéré courbit tout le temps des
vexations genève et intérêts on va là
alors si tu m'appelles monsieur je
refuse de te parler à ça je te le dis
tout de suite il va chez toi tu sais que
c'est quelque chose ça écoutez monsieur
tout cas encore si vous le prenez sur ce
ton d'accord je ne suis pas rancunier
vous êtes quoi monsieur tout comme
aujourd'hui
abbas est le point commun oui alors
aujourd'hui je suis sur une tête mais
bon bah oui bah tu parles août est comme
la mienne parce que ça serait pas
possible
oui mais sur une tête d'homme comme la
tienne armes sur une tête de femme comme
la tienne site était une femme
ouais ce que pour que j'existe battu sur
cette tête il faut qu'il y ait des
cheveux et même avec peu de cheveux je
peux exister et c'est faux quand même
connais un petit peu
tandis qu'avec les plumes à ben alors je
peux pas m'offrir ça tient fait voir toi
fais voir besta tête à la white est allé
par merveilleusement les commerciaux lte
en fabriquer une yeux les instruments
produiront parce que ça tu as vu la
tienne de tête ne recommence pas je me
mettre en colère
alors c'est à moi bon eh bien moi je
suis très simple au halo mais simple pas
compliqué du tout je vais d'un point à
un autre tout droit sans détour sans
examen jamais une femme qui crochet à
droite à gauche souvent jeudi ouazine
qui font exactement la même chose que
moi alors pour faire joli nous prenons
des couleurs différentes et nous
marchons comme ça côte à côte
remarque bien que nous faisons ça aussi
en noir et blanc c'est très amusant
tu sais nous fait ressembler à un zèbre
qui voient ce qui se dit oui oui un
zèbre
oui oui bien sûr oui oui oui m'enfin je
préfère écouter pouces mission parce que
la troisième version 20 métrage en suède
à moi à moi moi mon cher fabrice oui je
ne peux pas dire que je sois joli jeu il
tournait mais je suis très apprécié par
certains amateurs
on peut me rencontrer dans pas mal
d'endroits d'abord dans le fond de ton
fils est par exemple si si tu arrive
d'aller à la pêche en mer on peut un peu
plus tard on peut me voir sur l'état
l'âge de certains magasins
d'alimentation et par conséquent tu peux
aussi me trouvais dans ton assiette par
exemple eh oui et il y a beaucoup qui
met y en a beaucoup beaucoup qui
m'apprécient à ce moment là parce que je
ne leur pose pas de problème vois tu je
n'ai pas de pépins par exemple je je
n'ai pas de petit zoo et pas de petit
arrête tu as trouvé
ah oui voyons à oui je crois que j'ai
trouvé à trouver je crois en effet il me
semble que tout qu'on est une une ré
dans les cheveux ah ben oui bien sûr la
mesure a bah oui bien sûr encore
fallait-il le trouver et je pense que
bell bell est une oreille comme il ya
surtout sur du tissu en face on lui
commune reuse larreguy ça et puis vers
entendu pouces moussu serait plutôt
millar est le poisson
oui oui celle que vous appréciez au
beurre noir par exemple
adamu ça j'imagine ans mention au revoir
belbel à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
allez c'est à toi je vous demande pardon
à laon bat vous n'auriez pas de l'amendé
de 100 francs
c'est pas le moment on n'a pas la
monnaie de chansons ici c'est le jeu
avec fabrice bon petit jeu pousse moussu
c'est notre jeu et oui on y va car il
sort d'anne traduit barre n'est pas
fâché non non je mens pas mansat alors à
nous et rangés comme 101 aux camelots
alors cette semaine c'est un mot en
huile être 8 à huile est un petit peu de
gymnastique pour lui ça fait du bien une
fausse europe
voilà on devient très bon gardien alors
la première lettre 1c europe 1 2 3 4 5 6
strip retrait et après la dernière un t3
alors maintenant je t'écoute être un
animal et et ben non c'est vraiment un
animal alors c'est une fleur ouais eh
ben dis donc tu vas vite un rôti va très
vite oui c'est une hotte leur bon une
belle fleur alors comme ça peut être que
cette fois une petite fleur que nous
voyons dans nos champs oh oui oui
beaucoup dans les jambes dans les champs
dans les chaînes et elle est plus à noël
et pas bleue elle et elle est rouge
attend veux-tu te donne peut-être une
lettre à l'asie tu veux une lettre oui
alors la troisième la troisième lettre
c'est un cul voilà tu es sûr que ça
s'écrit comme ça haarde
bien sûr ça alors j'en suis sûr avec un
qi 6es avec un culot oui voilà est ce
que par hasard tu fais pas en train de
nous diriger vers une erreur manifeste
d'écriture en ayant son jeu
et dans ta naïveté première ou
coquelicots au coquelicot bien sûr y
assure qu'il s'écrit normalement épi li
qu un kopeck rompu elle hissée au tc au
cul oui voilà bon eh bien je crois que
ton cas est désespérément désespérée des
désespérés rare parce que coquelicots et
tout le monde est en train de se moquer
de toit au ccri c'est au cul et à eux et
non pas comme un coq dans un coq un code
qui s'appelait nico gino savard embellie
après si tu as un mensonge tout confort
j'ai encore pouces muslima on voit la
regarde ma sa coque e lyco ça s'est fait
comme ça
quant à toi j'espère ans tu vois tu vas
tout cancan quand as tu vois tout quand
tu ferais mieux de te taire que de venir
en aide à un ami pour dire des choses de
ce genre d'un abattoir
enfin il ya une chose que je peux dire
aux tonga fabrice oui quelque chose que
je peux dire c'est que le coquelicot
c'est une fleur très fragile elle se
fane très vite mais il ya un truc car il
ya un truc pour l'empêcher de se faner
trop butin il faut avant de les tremper
dans l'eau brûlé l'extrémité de leur
tige comme ça elles peuvent voir l'eau
dans laquelle tu les a plongés alors
d'accord tu vois ok faut les brûler
parfait en juin belbel ont rejoint mel b
mel draps
la twa fabrice vial jouer avec moi là là
c'est pas si la musique tibétains oui et
non bb je vais te raconter une histoire
et dans cette histoire celle est
certainement inachevé tu complètent ces
mots par des notes de musique en cash
voilà et quand c'est fini toutes les
notes de musique qui a placé forme le
début de la chanson dont je vais te
raconter l'histoire je te que cela se
passe dans un pays où il ya toujours du
même oeil
et il y a toujours des feuilles du
soleil du soleil du samedi salle à quoi
et les décors c'est une construction en
pierre une construction très id solide
grâce un endroit où les gens du pays ont
l'habitude de venir se promener de
chanter alors que ce n'est pas
spécialement fait pour ça c'est fait
pour passer de l'autre côté de l'eau
mais eux ils viennent là pour danser
comme je te le dis pour chanter et ils
se moquent hab
demain ils se moquent hab
sans lui ment il ment we all u man ils
se moquent absolument de ceux qui ont
besoin d'emprunter ce passage pour aller
travailler
est-ce qu'il ya très amusant c'est que
tous ces gens qui viennent là pour
danser et s'amuser
ce groupe par profession un jour on voit
arriver tout et blanchisseuse puis tous
les cordonniers
et puis les marchands de peaux de tas de
bouts de pain et de la peau de lapin
voilà mais naturellement il y aussi des
baisses d'impôts bronze ou des toits
pour nos poumons du rouleau un jeune
homme très fatigué alors de pousser
jamais révolue rappelle-t-on une
montagne des volets de faire de
l'alpinisme
oui on laisse nous finir pique encore
dans cette zone est également laisse moi
finir mon histoire parce que j'ai des
filets vides et naturellement il ya
aussi de belles dames et des beaux
messieurs
yann salué comme ça dans si la mêlée
plus amusant à voir sont ceux qui ont
des métiers président attendu je pense
par exemple au quart d'heure de mate mc
la malade est là et encore bien d'autres
personnes il ya des pires de cartes des
marchands nougat et des vers de carreaux
et bien des laveurs de carreaux qui a
trouvé oui alors vas-y tu t'écoutes sol
sol sol la la ça c'est le pont d'avignon
je faisais attention réside sur le pont
d'avignon
voilà ce qu'il fallait trouver encore un
petit coup soc 12 ans d'arrêt on y danse
on y danse sur le pont et cetera et
cetera les y'a bon monsieur
j'arrive tout schmidt rappelle lien avec
la bei d'argent il vaut mieux acheter
tonnes ce qui en fait de rater des
guides et les bals de produire un tennis
vient briser date l'année déjà papa de 4
environ petit peu près de la vie majed
s'est désisté et rzeszow fait des choses
les comme juni pas de mine war negro à
faire attention les cartes à mi ombre
par pas devant eux dit il ya çà me sont
heureux car ils aiment la mêlée
[Musique]
vous avez joué aujourd'hui et s'il dit
vouloir devenir familier
[Musique]